did you play any sports growing up did
you play any i could see you doing like
baseball i could see you like baseball
and you're like the guy that bunts every
time or something and they send you in
you're like the mighty bunt they say
bunt with your dick just stick it out
there and let it hit you in the nuts and
then it's gonna go about a foot and then
you run and i go if you can run
a dick by a bullet i go how would i do
that i go you don't have any feeling
down there do you don't you have like a
little puss and i go well that's rude
yeah
and also it's a coach talk cause i'm a
coach i'm not a scientist i'm just
guessing by eyeballing you so but i
would i did play second base and uh i
did like oh yeah i loved it i loved
baseball and
that's the hot corner second base is the
hot corner second base was hot it was
actually more responsibility than you
think oh no i i think it's all the
responsibilities short sucks too but but
those are the two good ones but you're
getting shelled yeah i mean that's
there's action and then the coach is
like this [ __ ] pip squeaks getting
too much action and then the worst is in
third grade that the the picture went
down oh what happened i got called up
like wild thing to pick yeah
the biggest puss in the [ __ ]
tri-state area they go spurt you're up i
go up one i go i can barely throw it to
first from second so
and i have one bounce so
i pitched i and i was like this doing
all the histronics like stretching and
[ __ ] i was terrified were you licking
your face like do you even know what did
we like doing some of the reasons yeah i
was like i had like a cornhole bag
spinning it around i didn't know why and
then uh it looked professional and then
i put eye black on yeah
i was i was sharpening my cleats
i was like are we starting it and then i
pitched and these guys were so excited
because it was just home run derby i
think i got 11 hits in a row and then
they go what were we thinking coach
fired there was a uh a quick vote in the
stands to fire the coach
yeah dude one time i remember this guy
through the it was my first time ever at
bat right and we hadn't even had a
practice bro that was our team
and we were the playville cubs
but some of they'd messed up some of the
jerseys and some of them said club some
of them said like
it was flubs it was like look yeah like
it was just none of it made any sense
dude i get up there
this is baseball this is yeah this is
basically football it could have been
either one but it was baseball
so i get up there the guy
throws it at me right so hard it hits me
this guy eric king
he was like had the toughest arm in town
dude yeah and uh he throws it at me it
hits me i vomited puked right out of my
own mouth
and you got hit so hard oh dude it was
it was unbelievable he was the best
thrower you know semi-local thrower
and he hit me and i
vomited
and they called a strike bro and i was
like
fixed oh bro 100
then another time i finally got on base
it was like the eighth game of the
season i don't even i think there was
like a plate tectonic shift and
literally like uh i just slid from home
plate over to first base like i didn't
really naturally get there by any skill
of my own a platonic shift yeah and so
the ground just like went up on one side
and it was like
yeah and so i'm at first times that
happens so i'm like i got a steal dude
if you if you can't do anything else you
got to steal a base if you're going that
was a tension getter though a stealer oh
that's a tough move oh a very hard dude
especially if you have white legs
so dude i get out there and i went for
it
halfway through i get appendicitis bro
my appendix busts
i'm laying on the ground
crying dude crying is it after you got
hit in the appendix oh no this is like
eight games i was about to say no one's
connected those dots yeah so i'm out
and i'm just bawling dude it was
absolutely what a plus in front of
everyone you're crying oh yeah because
it was so much pain my appendix it was
like i don't even know what happens i
think you get like
sepsis or whatever something happens but
you know i was dying on the inside and
the coaches i get to forget to sick and
you and just yelling racial and sexual
slurs at me sure queer you know just
like get there all the things i'm
against saying but yeah but yeah you
said yeah that people would pepper those
in in the old days oh yeah not cool and
it really was humiliating
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one